IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS IS THE FIVE.
♪
>> Kimberly: IT'S ON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOT SITTING
BACK QUIETLY WHILE HIS
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
DISPARAGES HIM TO THE MEDIA
AND TO READERS OF HIS NEW
TELL-ALL BOOK A HIGHER
LOYALTY.
COMEY HURLED ALL KINDS OF
ACCUSATIONS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT COMPARING HIM TO A
MOB BOSS WHO IS, QUOTE,
UNETHICAL AND UNTETHERED TO
TRUTH.
IN A CLIP JUST RELEASED, HE
ALSO DISCUSSES THE INFAMOUS
DOSSIER.
>> DID YOU TELL HIM THAT THE
STEELE DOSSIER HAD BEEN
FINANCED BY HIS POLITICAL
OPPONENTS?
>> NO.
I DON'T THINK I USED THE
TERM STEELE DOSSIER.
I TALKED ABOUT ADDITIONAL
MATERIAL.
>> DID HE HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW THAT?
>> THAT IT HAD BEEN FINANCED
BY HIS POLITICAL OPPONENTS?
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT.
IT WASN'T NECESSARY FOR MY
GOAL, WHICH WAS TO ALERT HIM
THAT WE HAD THIS
INFORMATION.
>> DID YOU TELL HIM YOU
THOUGHT IT WASN'T TRUE OR
YOU DIDN'T KNOW IF IT WAS
TRUE OR NOT?
>> I NEVER SAID I DON'T
BELIEVE IT BECAUSE I
COULDN'T SAY ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER.
>> DID YOU BELIEVE HIS
DENIAL?
>> HONESTLY NEVER THOUGHT
THESE WORDS WOULD COME OUT
OF MY MOUTH BUT I DON'T KNOW
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WITH PROSTITUTES
PEEING ON EACH OTHER IN
MOSCOW IN 2013.
IT'S POSSIBLE BUT I DON'T
KNOW.
>> Kimberly: I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT LANGUAGE FOR A SECOND
THERE.
MR. TRUMP HAS SOME WORDS OF
HIS OWN THIS MORNING,
CALLING COMEY A PROVEN
LEAKER AND LIAR.
A WEAK AND UNTRUTHFUL SLIME
BALL WHO WAS A TERRIBLE
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
HE SAYS IT WAS HIS GREAT
HONOR TO FIRE COMEY.
WELL, SARAH SANDERS WAS JUST
ASKED ABOUT THAT ATTACK ON
THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR.
>> ISN'T ALL OF THAT A BIT
UNBECOMING OF THE PRESIDENCY
OF THIS WHITE HOUSE TO GO
AFTER HIM IN SUCH A PERSONAL
WAY LIKE THAT?
>> I THINK.
>> CALL HIM A SLIME BALL AND
A LIAR AND LEAKER.
>> UNBECOMING FOR THE PERSON
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
TOP LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL
IN THE UNITED STATES.
THE PERSON THAT IS SUPPOSED
TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE OF
THIS COUNTRY TO LIE AND LEAK
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION,
CERTAINLY TO FALSIFY
DOCUMENTS.
I DIDN'T ENCOURAGE JAMES
COMEY TO GO OUT AND DO A
P.R. CAMPAIGN.
CONGRESS HAS ASKED JIM COMEY
TO COME AND TESTIFY MULTIPLE
TIMES, OF WHICH HE DENIES
BEING ABLE TO DO.
YET, HE FOUND TIME TO SIT
DOWN WITH GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS FOR FIVE
HOURS.
>> Kimberly: OKAY.
SO OBVIOUSLY SOME ROUGH
STUFF THERE IN TERMS OF
GOING BACK AND FORTH.
PEOPLE THOUGHT THIS BOOK WAS
GOING TO BE QUITE EXPLOSIVE.
YOU SAW THE START-UP THIS
MORNING WITH THE PRESIDENT
TWEETING.
YOU SAW THE REACTION ON
SOCIAL MEDIA AND ONLINE.
SO WE TAKE YOU AROUND THE
TABLE AND REFLECTIONS GREG?
>> THIS ISN'T DEEP THROAT.
IT'S MORE LIKE GOSSIP GIRL.
THE WHITE HALF MOONS UNDER
HIS EYES?
THAT'S A REVELATION?
WE NOTICE THAT EVERY TIME HE
IS TALKING BECAUSE HE IS OUT
ON THE GOLF COURSE.
COMEY IS IN THIS ETERNAL
STATE OF SURPRISE OR
EMOTIONAL ANGUISH.
HE IS ALWAYS CONFLICTED AND
THINGS ARE BOTHERING HIM.
HOW DO I DEAL WITH THIS AND
THEN THIS HAPPENS.
HE IS ALWAYS THE WORLD IS
ALWAYS HAPPENING TO HIM.
RIGHT?
AND HE IS JUST THE EVERY
MAN, THE JIMMY STUART.
HE SAID WHEN HE MET TRUMP,
HE SAID IT REMINDED HIM OF A
MAFIA BOSS AS IF THAT'S A
PROBLEM.
I MEAN, IF THAT -- IF THAT'S
A PROBLEM, WHEN YOU ARE
DEALING WITH NORTH KOREA AND
PUTIN, I THINK AMERICA MIGHT
SEE THAT AS A PLUS.
I WOULD MUCH RATHER HAVE, I
GUESS, A MAFIA BOSS THAN A
GRAD STUDENT T.A.
I THINK THAT'S LIKE THAT'S
YOUR REVELATION?
IT'S A VERY EMOTIONAL BOOK.
IT'S LIKE -- IT'S A TELL-ALL
BY AN EX.
LOOKING FORWARD TO ONE OF
THOSE.
>> Kimberly: HE IS GOING
THROUGH THE WHOLE POETRY.
>> YES.
>> Kimberly: WHERE ARE WE
GOING HERE WITH THIS.
RIGHT?
EXACTLY.
DANA, WHAT DO YOU THINK IN
TERMS OF THE ROLL-OUT FROM
THIS FROM A COMMUNICATIONS
PERSPECTIVE?
>> Dana: FOR WHO?
FOR THE PRESIDENT?
>> Kimberly: FOR COMEY,
FIRST.
>> Dana: I THINK IT'S
TEXTBOOK.
THEY HAVE BEEN PITCHING THIS
BOOK EVER SINCE HE GOT THE
ADVANCE TO WRITE IT.
THE PREORDERS WERE PROBABLY
OFF THE CHARTS.
HE IS GOING TO BE THE
DARLING OF THE MEDIA FOR THE
NEXT SEVERAL DAYS.
BUT, I DO THINK WHEN HE IS
TALKING ABOUT THE MAFIA
BOSS, IT'S NOT ABOUT FOREIGN
POLICY.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
DEMANDS FOR LOYALTY FROM
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THE
GOVERNMENT AND THAT'S WHAT
COMEY SAYS LED TO HIS BEING
FIRED BECAUSE HE WASN'T
GOING TO BE THAT PERSON.
>> Gregg: I LIKE THE WHOLE
PACKAGE.
IF THAT'S PART OF BEING A
MAFIA BOSS, OKAY.
>> Kimberly: OKAY.
TO EACH HIS OWN.
>> Dana: IF IT WERE OBAMA
SAYING THAT TO HOLDER WE
WOULD CREDIT WE DID
CRITICIZE HOLDER FOR NOT
BEING AGGRESSIVE AND
INDEPENDENT ENOUGH AND
DEFENDING THE PRESIDENT WHEN
HE DIDN'T DESERVE IT.
>> Gregg: IT COMES DOWN TO
ONE FACT THAT THERE IS A
CERTAIN KIND OF PERSON WHO
RUNS FOR PRESIDENT, TRUMP
ISN'T THAT PERSON, NO MATTER
HOW HARD YOU WANT HIM TO BE
MITT ROMNEY OR AL GORE.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT.
>> Gregg: HE DID.
HE DID IT WITHOUT THE PURITY
TEST.
ALL POLITICIANS KNOW HOW TO
FAKE.
>> Kimberly: WOW.
>> Jesse: DEFINITELY ACTS
LIKE A MOB BOSS.
HE'S NOT A MOB BOSS.
I THINK COMEY A LITTLE
SENSITIVE TO PICK UP WITH
WHAT GREG SAID.
HE REMINDS ME OF THE KID
THAT DIDN'T REALLY HAVE THE
STOMACH TO CONFRONT SOMEONE
FACE TO FACE.
AND THEN LATER RAN BACK AND
SCRIBBLED IT DOWN IN HIS
LITTLE DIARY AND WROTE IT IN
HIS LITTLE NOTE PAD AND NOW
HE IS JUST TRYING TO PROF
PROFITEER OFF OF IT LIKE
MOST PEOPLE TRY TO PROFIT
OFF THE PRESIDENT.
HE BOTCHED TWO
INVESTIGATIONS, THE HILLARY
AND THE TRUMP INVESTIGATION.
AND HE IS NOW REALLY
MUDDYING THE WATERS WITH THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
HE IS ONE THE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE CENTERPIECES FOR
THIS.
AND HE IS RUNNING HIS MOUTH
AND HE IS WRITING
TELL-ALL'S.
THE WAY HE TALKS ABOUT THE
DOSSIER IS DISTURBING, TOO.
THIS DOSSIER WAS PAID FOR BY
HILLARY.
YET, HE DIDN'T FEEL THE NEED
TO TELL THE PRESIDENT-ELECT
THAT HIS BIGGEST NEMESIS WAS
THE ONE THAT PAID FOR IT AND
GOT IT OUT IN FRONT OF
EVERYTHING?
THAT SEEMS TO BE A CRITICAL
PIECE OF INFORMATION.
I THOUGHT GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS DID A REALLY
NICE JOB ASKING ABOUT THAT.
THE WHOLE THING ABOUT HE IS
A LIAR AND LEAKER, YOU CAN'T
REALLY DISCOUNT THAT, TOO.
HE TESTIFIED UNDER OATH THAT
HE NEVER LEAKS.
YET, HE LEAKED THIS MEMO TO
HIS BUDDY.
AND THEN IT HIT THE PRESS.
SO HE IS A LIAR AND LEAKER.
THAT'S THE TRUTH.
I DON'T THINK THIS GUY -- HE
IS SUPPOSED TO BE A LAW MAN.
AND, YOU KNOW, HE SOUNDS
LIKE A SCHOOL GIRL IS THE
BOTTOM LINE.
HE IS EMOTIONAL.
HE IS SOCIALLY AWKWARD.
HE CAN'T EVEN BE ALONE WITH
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
HOW WEIRD IS THAT?
>> Maria: ARE YOU SERIOUS?
>> Jesse: LIKE A CHILD WHO
IS NOT REALLY WHO I WOULD
THINK BE THE ONE, THE
LEADING LAW MAN IN THE
COUNTRY, THE TOUGH GUY WHO
TAKES PEOPLE DOWN.
I THINK YOU CAN STILL SAY
THAT IN THIS DAY.
>> Gregg: YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BE GENDER-SPECIFIC.
BE GENDER-NEUTRAL.
>> Jesse: A CHOIR BOY.
>> Maria: JIM COMEY IS NOT A
PERFECT ADVOCATE FOR
DEMOCRATS OR REPUBLICANS.
MY PARTY HATES WHAT HE DID
TO HILLARY CLINTON IN
REOPENING THE INVESTIGATION
AND NOT TELLING THE PUBLIC
ABOUT THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION.
I'M NOT GOING TO DEFEND JIM
COMEY ON HIS FACE.
I WILL SAY THE BOOK FITS
INTO A NARRATIVE ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT AND THE
PRESIDENT'S RESPONSE
UNDERSCORES SOME OF WHAT
JAMES COMEY IS SAYING THAT
HE IS EGO-DRIVEN, THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS EGO DRIVEN.
IS HE NARCISSIST.
THE REMARKS FROM THE
PRESIDENT IS LIKE A SCHOOL
YARD BULLY IF YOU WANT TO
CONTINUE WITH YOUR ANALOGY
HERE.
SO, LOOK, WHAT MATTERS MOST
IS NOT THIS MEDIA BLITZ.
IT'S GOING TO GO ON FOR A
COUPLE DAYS.
IT'S BOB MUELLER.
YOU ARE RIGHT THAT JAMES
COMEY IS A KEY PLAYER IN
THIS.
THIS BOOK WILL BE
INTERESTING AND GOSSIPY.
WHAT BOB MUELLER FINDS ABOUT
JIM COMEY'S ROLE AND
OBSTRUCTION IS WHAT WILL
MATTER IN THE END HERE.
>> Kimberly: THIS IS PRETTY
STRONG LANGUAGE, WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT, FOR THE
FORMER HEAD OF THE FBI IS TO
SAY THE PRESIDENT IS
UNETHICAL AND UNTETHERED TO
TRUTH AND INSTITUTIONAL
VALUES.
THAT IS MAKING A VERY STRONG
STATEMENT.
THEN AGAIN, HE DID GET FIRED
BY HIM.
SO THE PROBLEM IS YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A SITUATION
LIKE THIS, DANA, WHERE
OBVIOUSLY THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE TWO WAS FRAUGHT
AND MAYBE THE TRUTH IS
SOMEWHERE.
>> Dana: I THINK THE BOOK IS
GOING TO REINFORCE ANY
PRECONCEIVED NOTION HAVE YOU
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP OR JIM
COMEY.
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT WHO
THINKS HE DID THIS FOR
HILLARY CLINTON AND ALSO,
REMEMBER, WE DIDN'T EVEN
BRING THIS UP THAT HE SAYS
THAT HE THOUGHT HILLARY
CLINTON WAS GOING TO WIN;
THEREFORE, THAT'S WHY HE
DECIDED TO REVEAL IT SO SHE
WOULDN'T LOOK LIKE AN
ILLEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
BUT IF YOU ARE THE TRUMP
CAMP -- IF YOU ARE IN THE
HILLARY CAMP OH REALLY SO
YOU HURT US.
AND YOU PROTECTED PRESIDENT
TRUMP?
AND YOU DIDN'T TELL US THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS UNDER
INVESTIGATION?
>> I THINK THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE A LOT TO BE MAD AT.
>> Kimberly: GO AHEAD, GREG.
>> Gregg: TO THAT POINT, HE
WOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT IF IT
WAS CLOSE.
YOU ONLY DID IT BECAUSE YOU
THOUGHT IT WASN'T CLOSE.
HIS DECISION WAS PURELY
POLITICAL.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
HE WAITED A MONTH UNTIL THEY
RELEASED THAT TO THE PUBLIC.
>> Kimberly: WAS THE ETHICS
INVOLVED HERE WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT IT?
THIS IS A MAN WHO WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE THE HEAD OF
THE FBI, LEADING THE BEST
AND BRIGHTEST.
NOW LOOK IN THE AFTERMATH OF
WHAT HAS OCCURRED IN TERMS
OF COMEY, THE
INVESTIGATIONS, THE
COLLUSION THAT HAS COME OUT
IN TERMS OF STRZOK AND PAGE
AND WHAT THEY WERE UP TO.
THAT'S REALLY DONE DAJ.
AND THIS WAS UNDER HIS
LEADERSHIP TO THE AMERICAN
CONCEPTION OF IT.
LOOK, FINE FBI OFFICERS.
THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT I
HAVE WORKED WITH THROUGHOUT
MY CAREER, I HAVE THE UTMOST
RESPECT.
THEY WORK VERY HARD FOR VERY
LITTLE MONEY.
THIS IS NOT GOOD OR HEALTHY
AS A COUNTRY TO HAVE THIS.
IT SEEMS TO ME, WHEN I READ
THIS LIKE POETRY AND THE EYE
THING.
IT SEEMS LIKE SHAKESPEARE IN
THE PARK.
FBI, PRESIDENT, LET'S GET IT
TOGETHER.
>> Jesse: IN THE NATIONAL
REVIEW JIM GARETY WROTE A
VERY GOOD PIECE AND HE
MENTIONED A LOT OF FBI
OFFICIALS WHO HAVE HAD LONG
CAREERS THERE.
PEOPLE DEFEND THE JAMES
COMEY IN THE BEGINNING.
THEY DIDN'T LIKE THE WAY HE
WAS FIRED BY THE PRESIDENT.
NOW THEY ARE COMING OUT AND
SAYING, LISTEN, IT'S ALWAYS
ABOUT JIM COMEY.
HE IS A CELEBRITY.
ALWAYS WANTS THE SPOTLIGHT
ON HIM.
WE GAVE HIM THE BENEFIT OF
THE DOUBT IN THE BEGINNING.
NOW IT'S LOOKING LIKE AN EGO
PLAY.
THEY DON'T LIKE THAT.
THEY LIKE TO FOCUS ON THE
FBI DELIVERING RESULTS, NOT
THE POLITICIZATION OF THE